[Musique]
quarante mètres de long et 190 tonnes de
béton a découpé en trois parties
un chantier qui ne passe pas inaperçu
dans ce quartier de la gare très
fréquenté la rue stephenson à montigny
le bretonneux a été fermée à la
circulation pour permettre la
déconstruction de cette passerelle
nous avons par levage progressif en
trois tronçons distincts pour la poser
au sol et pouvoir ainsi procédé à la
déconstruction du béton le plus gros des
colis faisant 78 tonnes et la distance à
laquelle on doit la poser au sol a
nécessité la présence d'une grosse
grosse grue de levage
une opération spectaculaire pour une
passerelle historique
cela faisait quarante ans qu'elle relier
la gare de saint quentin en yvelines à
l'immeuble internationale ce dernier
sera entièrement réaménagée en deux
parties vingt mille mètres carrés de
bureaux et 130 logements
nous avions en charge le curage du
bâtiment donc nettoyer tous les
bâtiments restitution du béton nu
ensuite des vaisseaux grosse opération
de désamiantage à ce genre de bâtiment
ayant énormément d'amiante et la
déconstruction de parties de bâtiments
en vue de la reconstruction de nouveaux
logements ribeiro afin de déblayer la
passerelle la rue stephenson restera
fermée à la circulation jusqu'à vendredi
les travaux de démolition de l'immeuble
se poursuivre jusqu'en avril d'ici là
l'avenue de la gare est modifié il
faudra attendre 2020 pour voir le
nouveau visage du quartier